[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we will be talking about
the new good mythical morning but more
specifically the response we've gotten
to the new good mythical morning and how
we as creators have been and as humans
taking have been taking it taking it
I've really been taking it right in the
whoop in the ear here's in spoiler alert
we haven't been taking it that well no
well it's an interesting thing what
we'll get into all that but well we
should just give it but aren't nothing
going to get into all that right now
well okay so after a couple of episodes
then in a good mythical more we had we
addressed some feedback on the show
being longer with four videos with
different things happening it's amazing
how good I felt after after recording
that video but it wasn't up yet and I
was just giving I just felt like I was I
was honest and I was addressing some
misconceptions and you know it's it's
something we've done before and then
when it comes out whenever whenever
something goes sideways and that maybe
we didn't anticipate and we get negative
feedback if we like right along comment
explain ourselves or if we make a vlog
or do like we did in good mythical more
and explain ourselves that it we tend to
get on the same page with the audience
and in anticipation of that I actually
felt better because I'm like oh gosh I
just wish I could respond to all these
comments but I think what we're doing I
don't and I think this I don't know if
that it that just that didn't put it to
rest
I'm so I'm I think this is an
opportunity for us to talk at length
about it and even more episodes have
come out and more comments have come in
and the conversation continues so yeah I
think weeks another data point we can
put you know we can talk even more I
don't wanna say candidly because we
talked very candidly and go more but I
think well we will talk a little bit
more candidly in terms of like our
feelings about it because we've because
we have we haven't talked about we
legitimately just a second ago we were
like oh we got to do an air biscuit and
we're like well let's just talk about
how we've been processing this whole GMM
thing and like the comments how we've
been dealing with it the conversations
we've been having because for a couple
of minutes yeah and but then we were
like no let's just take this whole time
until you we thought we might just do
the intro but we're gonna do the whole
thing and so we haven't planned what
we're going to say so again this is this
is one of the great things about your
biscuits I would hope from your
perspective is that this is a like a
real-time processing of how all the
stuff and of course we're recording this
about a week and a half or so before
it'll go up so who knows what will
happen in next week event we can happen
this is this is where we're processing
good mythical morning a week and a half
into the new format having gotten that
much feedback from people so and maybe
let's take a step back in order to set
the table
I I assume as a listener you've you've
watched the episodes and you've even
watched us give feedback in that good
mythical more where we said our response
to your comments or whatever I think
that's what we call it or something very
similar to that but for many and some so
some of this is by way of review but for
many many months we've been planning the
expansion of good mythical morning
without making an announcement about it
and we knew from the moment that we were
going to dramatically change good
mythical morning by making it longer and
by breaking it up into episodes breaking
the episode up in the segments that it
was a danger we were in a danger zone oh
yeah you know because if it ain't broke
don't fix it and it
no you hear this in the comments it's
like if it ain't broke don't fix it I I
wasn't asking for anything different but
we were convinced that we needed to
expand the show we needed to do
something well you do something
different with it more specifically
because I think this is one of the
things that will happen hopefully to
this conversation is those of you who
have asked specific questions about why
why did you guys do this if it ain't
broke don't fix it so why did you do it
we're gonna answer that those of you who
many many different accusations about
you guys obviously are just doing this
for money and you guys didn't address
that in your good mythical more candid
conversation so it wasn't that candid
because you didn't just come out and
admit that you're doing this for money
we're gonna talk about that and address
that directly we are ok great and again
we have no outline but yeah yeah because
I've been I've been thinking
specifically about those things and I
didn't you know I I didn't know that we
would get a response to our response
that was that was that it was like come
on guys it's just obviously a lot about
money so I just want to talk very
candidly about exactly why we're doing
this and then and then like what it has
been like to to process it first of all
and I'll also just go ahead and say that
it we haven't been when you look at this
mathematically speaking right let's just
say 500,000 people watch a video out of
500,000 people who watch a video a
couple thousand people comment out of a
couple thousand people who comment a
couple hundred people say something
negative actually vocalizing and that
made me meet being generous it may be
less than a hundred and then of course
some people thumbs those comments up or
they reply to them but if you just look
at the percentage you're talking about
five hundred thousand people and you're
talking about around a hundred people
who are vocalizing something negative on
a video from a percentage standpoint
you're still talking about a fraction of
one percent of people who are vocalizing
so it is important for us to put those
things into perspective
because many of you have said very
positive things and so I just want to
say up front that first of all thank you
for for everybody who's been very
positive we're not asking you to be
positive like that's not why we do
anything we don't get upset when we get
negative comments and be like why are
people so hard on us why can't everybody
just like everything that we do know we
know the game that we're playing we've
been playing it for 11 years we make
Internet videos so we know that this is
a two-way conversation and we know that
our content is shaped by audience
reaction we're very familiar with that
but I think you might be interested to
hear how we process it and how we kind
of balance the emotional toll that
negativity takes on a creators work with
the sort of challenge and opportunity
that it presents because I think that is
the job of every creator but especially
people who create things on the internet
so I think there's just a whole mindset
that goes into this that's kind of
developed over a decade of doing this
and there have been these big waves that
have kind of crashed on us to help shape
who we are and this is the latest wave
and we're kind of in the midst of it
crashing on us and I think it would be
sort of an interesting picture to kind
of break that down what it's like to
have the ocean crash into your face well
I think one thing is trying to identify
and as we're able to talk to each other
we're able to help sort this out in what
is a what is an emotional response and
what is an unproductively what is an
unproductive response and what you know
so I do think that there is there isn't
in there's a knee-jerk fear response in
that that we felt a handful of times or
at least articulated to each other that
is man is this thing that we've built in
this show that has been successful have
we killed it
you know we literally have asked
ourselves that that's come up
conversationally and it's not it's just
that's articulating the fear that that
could be happening you know and that's a
fear honestly that has always existed
for the everything that we've done but
there's more fear we like when you have
one thing that has a thousand episodes
and then you toy with it and then people
say after you released the first video
you have people saying well you lost a
subscriber it's that first you know it's
like the first response to that is an
emotional one and it is a fear response
oh my gosh if that person said that how
many other people are actually singing
that well then in in people go further
than that they some people qualify their
commitment before they qualify they
express their disk
with my family yeah for the past four
years or since season X and now we are
officially as a family departing from
the fold we are no longer going to watch
good mythical morning if this is what it
has become
and by literally the first day before
the first day and before you engage
before we engage rationally with that we
engage emotionally like the second you
read that especially when you're
scrolling through and your eyes stick to
everything that could be your worst fear
and just to give you a picture of how
this happens just legitimately literally
how this happens
at least for me it's last Monday morning
waking up to my alarm at 6:30 and
thinking for a second you know I could I
could just get up the healthy thing
would probably be she just get up take a
shower eat breakfast go to work and then
like process people's response but of
course we also had to make good mythical
morning that day right so the day that
it released is a day that we were making
more of more of it and we knew that we
had to pour over the comments if to see
if there was any adjustments that we
could make for what we were about to
shoot and and
what well so what it was like for me is
as I didn't I didn't get up I rolled
over because my alarm is my phone which
is probably a mistake in and of itself
and I didn't do that for a while but
then I went back to it and so I you know
I cut the alarm off and then I'm like
here we go
and I tap in to that first video and I
immediately see you know the show has
been up for about three and a half hours
at 6:30 our time and I immediately see
just a very large percentage of dislikes
you know we typically would get I don't
know if I if I wake up and I see more
than a hundred dislikes on something
traditionally by that point
hey like there's some what's wrong lady
what do we do wrong do we say something
are the cat lovers upset again what you
know what whatever we've done and
because and you say that because that's
what you saw this morning right they
they like now all of the mythical beasts
cat lovers are just not able to take a
joke decimated I won't get into that
right now
I'd guys I don't wish harm upon cats I
just think it's funny to act like I do
and get your responses that's for
another discussion but then turns out
it's not at this point in our emotional
state is not funny to get those
responses no it's not so so but but I
see the negativity and then I begin to
look at the comments and interestingly
the first thing that I see is a lot of
people talking about the lighting and
the color and the sound and I think you
might be so a lot of comments were like
guys how in the world would you think
this is better how could you let this
happen how could this happen how could
you be so excited about something new
and then it looks and sounds like this
you know that's a good it's actually a
really good question but I will say that
when my this isn't a defense it's just
an explanation when something has so
many moving parts and has changed so
significantly on the backend in order to
accommodate what we're trying to
accomplish there are things that quite
honestly fall through the cracks
it may seem crazy that something like
that would happen I can honestly say
that due to the schedule and the way
that everything worked that we didn't
actually see what exactly it would look
like before it went up and I think that
we got a lot of new team members and a
lot of things happen and a lot of moving
parts and not everyone really
appreciated just how important it was
for that first episode to look and feel
exactly like what you've known and loved
with GMM we had kind of communicated
that but I think that it's not everyone
is hard for anybody to we've experienced
that and we we anticipated that
experience but it was hard to convey
that it's like going it's like you've
got a favorite dish you've got a burger
that's made by a fast-food chain in a
very particular way and the special
sauce tastes a very particular way and
the burger is a certain way and then all
of a sudden you show up one day and they
say the big mac or whatever it is is
better and you're like but you change
the freakin special sauce and the meats
different now this isn't better I why
did you everyone loved it why are you
changing it all great legitimate
questions but but I think the answer is
we changed a decent amount of the
equipment that we use to make the burger
but our aim was to make the same burger
and we just didn't it was how to say
it's very hard to anticipate that some
equipment changes would make the burger
feel and taste any be experience and
this is I think this is a good analogy
which I and it's so frustrating when
it's like oh my gosh it's like that is
something we need we didn't
intentionally want to change and I know
it's so so much top of mind in the
comments it's like I you know at least
it's like we 100% agree and we're we're
fixing that as soon as we can well let
me say that I think that the fast food
restaurant analogy will hold up for a
number of these aspects including the
whole money thing which we'll get to in
a second but it isn't that we wanted to
change the specialty burger is that we
wanted to introduce new menu items in
addition to the burger yeah and in order
to do that we had to hire people and we
had to establish new systems
and initially the burger that you that
you knew and loved was compromised that
and we look you know unintentional I did
initially we learned a lot of we have
learned a lot of lessons already but
just know that the in some of these
first of all the color has been updated
the color is still being tweaked
there's we're still dialing things in
again its its new lights and this new
cameras which Ultraman ultimately are
much better and I think can create a
much better experience ultimately it's
4k and not everybody watches to 4k I get
that but we're kind of sort of future
proofing the show but we're continuing
to tweak it so especially that first
part of the show gets back to that place
where it's like that's the burger that I
know and I love and they're not but now
I've got these new menu items that have
been added to it that is the intention
that's the plan but we do acknowledge
that that's not exactly what happened
and the burger didn't taste is good yeah
we get it we let's act when we watched
back the first couple episodes we can
you guys think that you can see you can
see when we're not comfortable or when
there's something that we're thinking
about you know I actually saw a really
interesting interview with John Lithgow
talking about I told you about this but
talking about getting ready to film
daddy's home to and how with Marky Mark
and Will Ferrell Will Ferrell Gibson
yeah and how they all live together for
like a week before the shooting of the
movie to become comfortable with one
another because quote you cannot make
great comedy if you feel threatened and
I thought that was so profound because I
totally understood what he meant in our
career we've gotten into situations so
many times especially if you show up on
a set somewhere and this is the first
day working with this director this is
the first time working with this actor
like specially unlike a buddy system
situation and and we're meeting somebody
for the first time and in 15 minutes
later we're acting against them because
we don't operate at the budgets that are
required to go have a camping trip with
somebody for a week before you start
production nor do we have the time but I
totally relate to that because if
you feel any sort of discomfort or fear
and we were on this new set which is a
lot like the old set but it's new and
there were new people the same old
people but now new people in addition to
them yeah telling us everything you saw
was supposed to look the same but every
time we didn't yeah and everything there
we saw looks dramatically different and
the day before we shot the first episode
was the first day we we sat in the
chairs most of the day and like tweaked
through stuff but at a certain point you
just got to do it man and it was um we
weren't as ready as I wanted to be yeah
I mean I think you never are
yeah well and a first day of in
retrospect and we talked about this we
told you guys a lot we talked about this
on tour quite a bit that the combination
of writing the book and then going on
tour
finishing up buddy system and in this
starting gmm 22 we call a team of 22
because it adds up to at least 22
minutes this was too much for us
ultimately in the way that all these
things coincided because typically like
we were coming back from a trip to Texas
I believe and we basically got back had
one day looking at the new set and then
shot the show and that isn't ideally how
we would have done things especially in
retrospect when we look at ourselves and
we're like we just weren't in a groove
and we didn't complete we weren't
comfortable we felt threatened it may be
hard to understand for people who aren't
performers but you know how you act
differently amongst friends
and then within strangers right and
there's this comfort level that okay
these people know me and they know they
appreciate me for who I am and I can be
myself and I can mess up those things
translate into performance especially
with the type of show that we do which
is designed to be sort of rooted rooted
in an authentic experience by us and you
know what I think a silver lining is
that I think we really grew to
appreciate one of the strengths of this
the strengths I cannot speak
we really grew to appreciate one of the
strengths of our show which is honesty
you know I that I mean again there is a
there's a collective wisdom that we try
to glean from the comments and when
words like sincere sincerity or sincere
or honest or honesty come up in there
it's like okay that's something that I
think we we embodied but I think we are
much more intimately acquainted with
that being a cornerstone of what our
show is like a level of honesty in our
performance that it's actually
performance may not even it is a
performance but it's not do you know
what I'm saying it's not actually 100%
of performance it's it's like it's
honest being and it's a real there's a
real conversation you know we're being
ourselves there's real remarks we're
having in the moment and you know what
we're still every second we shoot
something I'm still thinking about can
this be more honest okay like because we
wanted to be funny we want it to be
great we want it to be the best we want
it to be awesome you know and you're
thinking about all these things and
we're trying a lot of different things
in this in the different segments and
it's a funny thing to be thinking about
am i being honest
yeah but it that's a nice byproduct to
this in terms of knowing that that's the
cornerstone of of of how we interact
with our show and yeah well let's talk
about why because I think that people
could be still asking what why why would
you do this and we haven't even talked
about what we're gonna say here so I
mean well let me just start by saying
that before any of this opportunity to
do this expanded GMM came along
Linc and I were having discussions about
when good mythical what's name of our
show good mythical morning good mystical
morning good mystical morning when good
mythical morning would end now that's
it's
you know if we would have talked about
what we were gonna talk about before we
were now talking about it we probably
would have I would have talked ourselves
out of you saying what you just said
right because I think and that's why I
didn't tell you and I and no I I think I
ultimately would have said of yeah we
should just we should talk about it I
mean I just talked about honesty for the
past couple of minutes so I'm I'm glad
that you said it but again it makes me
nervous that all of a sudden you're
nervous that what you were thinking
about they were thinking about quitting
good mythical morning or they're
thinking about quitting right now I will
tell you quitting is the farthest thing
from my mind right now
of course but because of what we've done
but because of this but then that was
that's the exact reason well let me
qualify because this is super candid so
I remember over a year ago just starting
the conversation and I and again this is
most often gonna come from me because I
write I'm always living in the next
moment and I'm living in the security of
something work yeah and and I and so and
not and I want to talk about we're gonna
get into all the money stuff in the in
the why because I think it's in it's in
our DNA right so the reason that over a
year ago I was initiating a conversation
just saying I think we should set an end
date and I didn't necessarily throw out
any times and it was it wasn't months it
was years an end date for good mythical
morning because the nature of what we do
and who we are is that we create and we
evolve and we change and we embark on
new challenges and that's what we get
off on and that's who we are and I know
that people don't want to hear that and
people like but this show means this
much to me and why would you abandon us
it's and and you know that's it it's
tough because we do understand that what
we do for some people is almost like a
service we're like in the service
industry of what we do and giving you
guys something but I'll be just quite
honest and say that I'm not gonna do
that it the the expense of my personal
sanity at the expense of my family's
sanity or health and also the reason
that we started good mythical morning is
because it was a new thing a new
challenge to embark on and I do think
that every
life should have a beginning middle and
end and I don't know when the end of
anything that we're doing is going to
come but it's just in our nature to say
let's not just let something just
dwindle off into oblivion but let's do
something really really well
for a certain amount of time and then
when it's time has come to end let's end
it and try something new and I've always
approached things we've always
approached things like that I might
initiate some of that but that doesn't
mean that's not the way that you also
approach things you just might need to
be talked into it but it's in your
nature as well well I remember one of
the main conversations we were having
and if you were to guess when when this
conversation happened well I'm about to
tell you so go ahead and get get the
guess in your mind it was on the way
back from Venice Beach after we were
shooting the roller skating seen from
buddy system season 1 mm-hmm
some we're talking a year and a half ago
guys that that we were talking about how
much longer yeah well cuz we were we had
taken a break from good mythical morning
to shoot buddy system and we were really
enjoying doing it it was like it was
super engaging for us it was like a new
muscle was being a new part of our brain
was being challenged and awakened and
but we were talking about what we had to
talk about going back to good mythical
morning cuz we you know we had to have
some preliminary discussions about
what's good you know the conversation we
normally have what's gonna change what's
good what do we want to bring to the
table
when we start shooting the next season
and the energy that we brought to it was
I just don't want to talk about it I
don't know if I want to do it you know
and we we knew we were going to do it
but we were just being honest about how
excited we were to do it and it wasn't
it was because it was going back to the
same thing we had done so much and is it
gonna really just be the same thing how
much stuff can we keep eating yeah I
mean that we specifically we're talking
about those things and well in this go
and this actually speak
just briefly sidebar it speaks to the
criticism that a lot of people have had
about good mythical morning over the
years and I see these comments kind of
being filtered in with everything else
that's going on now it's like why don't
you guys go back to what the show was
initially just two guys two friends
talking to each other well you guys
that's we're way past that we've been
past that for a number of seasons and
the very simple reaction to that is we
don't want we didn't want to do that
five times a week that's not what we
wanted to do it's funny we quickly
quickly ran out of stories to tell and
things to talk about and needed things
to do but I became in that same
conversation I proposed that I was like
not in the fall but then let's in
January let's go back and let's just
bare-bones this thing and let's make it
something like that cuz at least it'll
like shake us up and it'll be there we
know it won't be about anything that we
that we do besides the thoughts in our
mind and the words coming out of our
mouth by the way a lot of what we have
then funneled into ear biscuits
yeah and got excited about so it's not
that we weren't excited about having
conversations like the one we're having
right now
but but we've but we've we talked about
it and then that was the conclusion we
can't we can't take a step backwards but
we also remembered what it was like to
do that right so so before we get into
specifically the very specific catalyst
that led to why we're doing four videos
a day and why'd you see YouTube
originals everybody's like why do I see
youtube originals on every thumbnail
we're gonna explain all that but I just
wanna I want to talk quickly about our
trip to DC and how we went into the Air
and Space Museum and we spent a lot of
time at the Wright brothers exhibit and
it just a lot of things so we have like
crystallized in my mind about how I
wanted to explain what we do now let me
just start right up top by saying that
us comparing ourselves to the Wright
brothers is inherently pretentious and
I'm that's not what I'm not saying that
we're doing anything as significant as
building a plane we're not inventing a
whole new industry we're just making
Internet videos which the ones that get
the most
the ones in which link vomits okay this
is not sophisticated stuff there's
nothing to be commended about we're just
having a blast on the internet and we
found a loophole and we're getting paid
very well to do this that's just the
honest truth weird but we did play the
Wright brothers at one point in an epic
rap battle so we have some right and
they they the first flight was in our
homestay it was no they're from Ohio
where the people of Ohio claim them
there's a kindred spirit they did it in
North Carolina so screw you Ohio but
yeah they have this room that walks you
through what they were like as people
and then the different stages of
invention that led to the first powered
plane and all the floors plane and it's
there guys the literal plane all the
things in this particular exhibit I
think the reason that it resonates so
much with us is because you got these
two guys who are brothers who have known
each other their whole lives which
that's a great way to describe us either
a married couple or brothers more than
friends what about married brothers
marry first
that's us incestuous brothers oh I took
a left turn and and also working on
something that doesn't have an
incredible amount of outside influence
or precedent right so yes so it's just
like two dudes in a room kind of batting
things back and forth and constantly
updating things and trying to make it
better and having a goal and mine and
just working and probably fighting a lot
and arguing over that it was just such a
compelling story and then we saw the
different iterations of flight and one
of the first things that they ever did
of course they were bicycle mechanics at
first but then they went from they were
they moved on from being interested in
bicycles to saying okay let's figure
this flight thing out and I'm sure they
were incredible bicycle mechanics and
I'm sure that they were doing some
incredible things in the word a world of
bicycling and I'm sure they had people
who loved what they did with bicycles
but they weren't meant to just keep
doing bicycles because it was in their
nature to try to move to the airplane
and I'm sure that when they started
experimenting with flight there were
people who loved the
bicycles who got very upset with them
again this is a pretentious analogy I
don't think that what we're doing is a
significant is moving from bicycles to
flight but just stick with me stop being
so pretentious and then when they got to
this point where they actually at one
point they invented a kite that was a bi
wing kite that was up there on display
in this museum and this is the beginning
of them kind of figuring out gliding and
just the power of a wing way before they
got too propelled you know an actual
plane with a steering steering or yeah
or steering or a person on it and I'm
sure that kite was super cool and I'm
sure there were people who loved that
kite and we're like this is the coolest
thing you guys invented this awesome
double wing kite in some ways asking us
to continue to make the exact same show
to make the exact same product in the
exact same way
that people like is like telling the
Wright brothers to stop with a bicycle
or to stop with the bye wing it's in
their nature to continue to iterate to
learn to move to do things that could
potentially fail I mean they took a huge
risk when they stopped doing a very very
reliable business and started trying to
do something that was pretty harebrained
and crazy and people could get hurt and
people could fail and other people could
beat them to it but it wasn't like they
just started and said hey wouldn't it be
neat to make an airplane that's not how
this whole thing works and I think if
you're a creative person I think you'll
relate to this you can't help but create
and innovate if you're creative you're
not doing something to try to meet some
nebulous goal you're not doing something
to try to meet somebody's expectations
no you're literally doing it because you
cannot help the reason good mythical
morning has changed the reason that we
started good mythical morning the reason
that we did buddy system the reason that
we drove the book the reason that we did
a tour the reason that we're gonna do
whatever we're gonna do next year is
because we can't help it
we honestly can't help it that's the
starting point for everything that we do
it is in our DNA
we're built to do this kind of thing and
to create and innovate and we can't stop
it
the difficult thing is when you fail I
mean it was fascinating that once they
it was after they had patented
the plane that they started meeting with
people of course the first way to make
money is through through military
exploits of a plane and they were doing
a demonstration where they took a took a
guy up who was a potential buyer from
the military and they're like flying him
around and showing him the capabilities
and they crash and kill the guy he died
and Orville was very very seriously
injured in that as well and thank
goodness our failures are not life and
death but to us on an emotional level
sometimes I feel that it it's it's been
feeling that way every day for us
because every well I won't say every
single day but I would say every day we
shoot there's at least something or that
we're trying something in a segment that
is not what good mythical morning has
ever been it's it's something new that
is experimental and sometimes before we
do it we're like we have to we can't
film this if we don't believe in it we
have to believe in it or it's it's it'll
never take off so to speak and while we
believe in everything that we do we also
firmly believe that not everything is
going to work and some things you don't
we don't believe in as wholeheartedly as
other things and you know it's difficult
to give it you're to give it your best
and then when it and then when it's done
that's the next point you're like that
that didn't work and we're not at a
point because of the way we've committed
in terms of production to like building
these episodes we can't and I mean it's
this is not an ideal but we can't cut
something you know it's like so there's
a silver lining to putting something out
that's like you know what this is not
our best work and it is we're still
going to learn something and and you it
can be argued that you learn a lot more
from failure than from success but let
me tell you it's hard last night
you know Stevie Sena slack and she was
like fans aren't gonna like so-and-so
so-and-so segment and we're like what
and we're because she saw it and we're
like
we already knew that and then I'm like
can we pull it can't believe I can't
pull it you know and it's like you put
it out there and you learn you learn
you're like why are we wit now where
we're inviting more critical feedback
that we already know and that that that
that's like walking into a burning
building where there's no one to rescue
is what it feels like well you know if
you Mike listen this is just for our own
pain let's come back to the whole like
the way that we're seeing the process of
like throwing things out there and
learning okay
okay because I want to continue with a
story of yeah of like what why because I
still haven't talked about money and I
know everybody wants yeah we should we
should do that because so we've made the
point that work from a creative
standpoint we're compelled to remain we
have to remain engaged it's what we
talked about and it's just how we were
when we say things as audacious in some
of your minds as one day GMM will end or
we are having that conversation it's
because we know that when it ends
something else begins and that's what we
live for right and so and there is a
balance between wanting to do things
that make audiences happy because it's
so amazing how like there's people who
do daily vlogs and then they stop and
then the people can love you so much and
the day you change the thing that you've
been giving them it's they become like a
druggie who has suddenly been taken who
who's been taken off of their you know
their supply and they turn weary the
drug dealers in this innocent algae and
they suddenly hate the drug dealer and
so we I've seen it a million times how
quickly an audience will turn on you and
begin making all kinds of accusations
about how you've gotten to Hollywood you
lost focus you're not rooted anymore you
forgot who you are you forgot where you
came from it's all about the money and
this to begin just unloading judgment on
you and it can be it's it is it's you
know I love the relationship we have
with the fans and I love the fact that
we do take feedback and they have made
all this possible we couldn't two guys
just hanging out in a room being funny
with each other does not a job make
unless there are people to watch them
and then sell advertising a
that's how this whole thing works but it
just it's kinda be completely honest it
just kind of sucks to know that the day
that you take something away or you
change something the Avalanche
starts and it was never about liking you
it was about liking what you were being
given and I know that there's a lot of
mythical beasts who that's not what it's
about at all and I've been gonna be
supportive through everything and kind
of get this but there's a lot there's a
lot of people out there who this is a
very this is a transactional
relationship we produce they consume in
the moment we change that they they
consume they get very mad at the
producer and it's just a reality and I'm
not complaining
I'm not complaining about it at all we
signed up for this it's just an
unfortunate reality of humanity that
they're there it's not there's not it's
not a love relationship it's a consumer
relationship and the moment that it
changes they become very angry consumers
I get it it's just an unfortunate
reality but let's talk specifically
about the money because I think those
people who are levying this particular
accusation that just be honest guys you
did this to get more ad revenue four
times the videos four times the ad
revenue I think that that is I would
venture to say that the people who have
levied that accusation are a not
particularly creative people and B
definitely not business owners it's an
interesting thing to run a creative
business when your business is to
entertain people there are two things
that you have to weigh constantly the
first that you have to weigh is are you
creating something that is going to be
received well like are you doing a good
job creating the thing that you're
supposed to use to create to entertain
people but the second thing you have to
ask and you have to ask these questions
in tandem at the same time every single
time is is this a financially
responsible choice so and especially
when you get to a place where we're at
right now where this isn't just two guys
this is a this is a corporation has been
a corporation for years for like seven
years but now it's a place where a lot
of people are working a lot of people
are depending on their livelihood
there's dozens and dozens of people who
work at meth
entertainment so every sink we don't
just we're not just these dudes to come
in and just say on a whim this is what
we want to do today guys know we every
decision we make weighs how our company
and the people who work here are going
to be affected and frankly how our
futures are going to be affected and how
my kids college education is going to be
affected and how my retirement is going
to be affected and so we don't make a
decision that we don't see as
financially responsible that doesn't
mean we don't take risks this whole
thing was a risk but yes so when you say
it's just all about the money I would
say that it's not it is definitely not
all about the money but we do believe
that this was a wise financial decision
in the long term but that wasn't what
motivated it because we the creative is
the first thing that gets us going and
then we make sure that this decision is
one that is financially responsible but
the specifics of the decision I think
you should I mean and I would just say
from a I'll explain from a business
standpoint the reason why Google and
YouTube wants to invest in this is they
have their interest and we have our
interest now for them their interest is
to attract sponsors and add investment
into into YouTube so they can make more
money now they I'm not gonna say that's
their only interest I'm not them but you
can't they're still at a point in an
industry where we're trying to help
potential sponsors understand that
sponsoring internet content is just as
valuable or I would argue more valuable
than a television spot or radio spot or
whatever other type of billboard spot
that people are advertising it back up a
bus bench spot what whatever it is and
if you've just got these shareable
videos like in Internet videos
but you know they're just the people
with the money or just thinking well I'm
not gonna they just don't quite get it
yet but if you start to say okay there
is a there is original programming you
understand that on Amazon you understand
that on Netflix now advertiser well
YouTube this is YouTube talking we also
have that and we're creating properties
which have more engagement and a more is
more is you have a more powerful
opportunity to reach people with your ad
here than in those places but the thing
that helps it click into place for them
is if it's a show if it's like a
half-hour show and so that's why they
came to us with the opportunity to do it
you came at us they came to us at a time
and when I let me just say and our
interest in responding to that was this
is we want to continue to shape the
landscape of Internet a mint
you know I would love to fast 40 years
from now and see that there are people
coming up creating content that is seen
as just as legit as just as legitimate a
form of entertainment as the way people
think about Game of Thrones or any non
scripted show that is storage wars or
whatever the whatever's going on in the
world of non scripted entertainment or
cable television that was a big one a
few years back right we are we were
excited about again as part of
experimentation and helping to create
things that shaped the landscape and I
think if we just kept making those those
short form videos it wasn't gonna do
what this could potentially doing in
legitimately making good mythical
morning what most people not just
advertisers would think of as a show and
not just an Internet video that comes
out every day
what cuz they came to us at a time when
like I said we were having conversations
about well when is this gonna end like
is this all that this show can ever be
and then right when we're having those
conversations YouTube comes along and
says hey we're looking to invest in
some some YouTube original programming
that wouldn't be behind the paywall like
YouTube read so people don't have to pay
for it that's never gonna happen with
good myth that was a non-starter yeah
yeah good mythical morning is the kind
of show that will always be free so this
isn't like old the first step and the
next step is it's gonna be YouTube read
show nobody system is the kind of show
that it's financed in a different way
and has to be behind to pay well good
mythical morning is not but they came to
us and said we want to help you guys
make this show something bigger than it
is something that will be even more a
part of the cultural conversation and I
think this will answer some of your
questions because people are like well
YouTube is making them do this you
YouTube has changed the color somebody
at YouTube said it should be yellow
no the interesting thing is that we are
100% in charge of the creative we can't
do anything that that they would be like
okay well that's gonna piss off an
advertiser but we don't do that anyway
we've never like we don't do things that
are questionable and controversial so
that's why advertisers have always had a
home on our show but they said we want
to just give you guys the resources that
you need to do the thing that you want
to so the whole four videos a day
specifically what's going into each
video what we're trying to do with each
segment what we're going to continue to
try to do it's all coming from us and
our team mm-hmm and the team that you
has always been there we've it's up
lamented that team and we brought in new
people for more ideas but this is not a
YouTube is sitting there waiting for Oh
change this let's make it sound
different let's make you guys sound like
you're further away because that's what
we're about at YouTube let's make it
more yellow because yellow is the new
YouTube no guys those were things that
happened as a result of a lot of things
happening at once and us kind of losing
the ability to control every single
element but we very quickly course
corrected some of those technical things
but but we're the one who's who said
yeah so we we dictated it was all the
creative in the show comes from us and
our team intern but same way it has
always been yeah and we said yes to the
opportunity because we wanted to develop
the show for all the reasons we talked
about and just to just to make it add
more to it to add more size to the fast
food menu of good mythical morning maybe
even turn it into a sit-down restaurant
experience but to keep pushing it we
wanted to we knew we had to make them
segments you know the original
assumption was well you'll just have one
long video well we did that it's called
the mythical show and we said your half
hour of not having to click around on
the Internet well you know what turns
out people wanted to click around on the
Internet we were wrong it was a it was a
it was a lesson we learned that nothing
reaches out when you have a big honking
22 minute to 30 minute video so we knew
as an almost as another non-starter we
couldn't get in on this deal unless each
segment was its own video was its own
video wanted people to be able to
experience it the same way that you
experience any video that's about one
thing so they're wanting to also be a
show that you could watch together every
single day so it had I mean each segment
had to be able to trend it had to be
able to be shareable and comment aband
yes again and I think it'll work within
the ecosystem of YouTube now the thing
we asked from YouTube and that we're
still working on is let's make it make
these four videos plus one which is good
mythical more work in a way that doesn't
that feels more like a show that feels
like a show in that so those days
through like those are product changes
that are still being worked on just so
you know like so right now we've got it
set up so that you click on the green
video and that puts you in order and
sometimes that that particular episode
designation tool that segment as a
nation tool is not up and running
because it there's a lot of things that
have to happen there's technical things
that are being worked out anytime you're
innovating and trying something new
sometimes you can find that you're a
little bit ahead of the technology we've
we've seen this a million different
times and that's gonna be frustrating
for your experience but it's all gonna
be worked out because we're never gonna
get there if we don't start getting
there you never get there unless you
start going but I think that it's an
interesting thing to talk about the
the comments that we've gotten about
that like people saying things like guys
just put it in one video guys just put
it in one video and then also post all
the other videos on their own I like to
a vet brothers say people love to talk
about things they don't know about
people love to talk on things they don't
know about one of my favorite lyrics and
we're guilty of that a lot but YouTube
commenters are very especially guilty of
that people love to start offering their
opinion I actually saw one comment that
was like you guys should do
he actually laid out like a he has
schedule for how we were supposed to
should shoot our videos during the day
like shoot a video then take an hour
break then shoot another video then take
an hour break it's like the audacity
that people have to start giving
suggestions as if we haven't thought
about a lot of these things just mind
boggling sometimes I'm sorry to get
frustrated about it but it's just crazy
but specifically the people who have
said make one long video don't split it
up are not stopping to consider exactly
what link just laid out like we know how
YouTube works we've been doing this for
a very long time we know that if you put
a video up that has a bunch of different
things and isn't about one thing it
doesn't have nearly the reach that it
could have because yes we do want it to
get a lot of views and we do want it to
work and we do want it to be sustainably
sustainable financially that's why we
made the choices that we did and we're
up against some challenges with the
product but those challenges will be
overcome but it's just amazing to me how
quickly people begin to throw out things
and just I would just encourage people
just be like why don't I just stop and
think like maybe they thought about this
particular thing or maybe I should pose
this as a question well you can get
frustrated those comments but those are
ones that are easy to ignore get ignore
those there's no truth I just don't
think I don't think we should we should
be dwelling on that in in order to shift
the conversation I will say that
question mark amount of time down the
road if we if good mythical morning this
new version of the show is not better
than the old version
then we have failed and that is on us
yeah the two of us now definitely not
guaranteed to work no now that the it's
a risk the tough thing is is what's
gonna happen how long is it gonna take
for us to figure it out enough you know
we say thing and so that's why we're
still in the scary place and it's weird
because well we say things like well if
we make the first video what we call the
a block the first segment of the show if
we just give them basically the same
experience as good mythical morning this
is what we talked about before
I think that's cholesterin like they
don't you know if it's seven minutes
we're getting complaints it's like well
we got to make sure that we're making
that four we need to make that first
video the best video it can be and that
should probably that can we have an app
they have an appetite for that'd be a
little longer than the shorter version
is that we're making sometimes we will
if we're because we didn't intentionally
make them that short I don't think it
just kind of happened
I think actually I think we did I think
with like the weird ways open a cereal
box we did three as a before we do we
would do four or five and you know if we
used to do five and now we did three
maybe we'll do four well you know we're
those are reasonable tweaks that we'll
be making and I think in the short term
we just have to make sure that like if
we're saying all right the first video
is gonna be basically the old GMM
experience and then we're adding the
sides to your meal that you didn't get
before then it's just a question of
those other things that we're adding do
you find yourself wanting those over
time and if you don't then that's our
problem and that that is our challenge
like you know it's frustrating to get
over the speed bumps of the transition
of the technical stuff the color the
sound and you know the the stuff that
you never need to know about about the
backend of how things work now so that
you have the experience you want but
once you get through that it's like
are we actually gonna create a show
that's good
I mean well I is this is the second
segment is the third so let me say that
I think that well got two things number
one I don't think we finished the money
question I know you want to go back to
that all right so let's pause my
question let's go back to the money
coach because I said I was leading up to
something okay I never let me get there
all right yeah so I want to adequately
answer that because people are gonna be
like he's still dodging the question so
so we want to make money that's I mean
no that's not in order to have a
sustainable company that will outlive us
we want it to be financially sustainable
to run a company of this size does take
money so every decision that we make we
make sure that it is going to ultimately
be a better financial decision in the
previous decision that does not motivate
initial decisions we said a long time
ago we sat down many years ago and said
the only rule in this business is we
never make a decision just for the money
we will never just just do something
just for the money we are led by our
creative inclinations but then you bet
your butt that we're going to take the
best offer that we get we cheat we go
with the publisher that gives us the
best deal we go with the provider that
gives us the best contract because we're
responsible business people and that's
just the way we operate given that you
also given that people will let us do
what we want to do creatively which is
definitely the case with what we're
doing with YouTube but I will say that
we don't go off to Calabasas and buy
seven million dollar homes that's that's
not how we operate okay
there are youtubers who do that we've
never lived a lifestyle that was like
hey listen as much money out of this
company and hire as few people as
possible so we can go be rich fat
daddies that isn't how we operate that's
not what we're into we make good money
doing what we do but the vast majority
of what we make we reinvest into this
company and to other people and other
ideas and more of our ideas to try to do
the next thing and so while there's no
guarantee that this particular move will
be
or lucrative than if we had never done
it so it's not like okay we made X
amount of money and we're making 10x
money by doing this or we're making
Forex money that is definitely not the
case if you look well and it's also a
different structure and how all this is
happening
I just think well let me just finish my
thought finish your thought so it's not
like we're gonna be making four times as
much revenue by doing this you can look
at the numbers of how many views that
we're getting we didn't think that oh we
get a million and a half views on one
segment every day if we make four we'll
get six million views that we know
that's not how the internet works we're
not getting as many views on any one
segment as we would have gotten before
so that's not why we're doing what we're
doing if this is if this is successful
we stand to make more money with this
model than the other model but that
isn't the motivation for doing it and we
take all that money and we reinvest it
back into the company to continue to
develop new ideas because that's what
we're in this for we're not in it to buy
seven million dollar homes we're in it
to make incredible things that will
leave a legacy that's just that's why we
do what we do but I also don't think
it's fair or you know to put to be in a
position where we're defending our
purchases or that's true or honestly
critiquing how much other people pay for
their houses I mean no you're right
you're right let's not let's not do that
I I just don't think I don't I just
think that that I'm just saying there's
no evidence for saying you guys are all
about money there's no tangible evidence
in our lives if even if but honestly I
didn't care about money if you want to
well I feel like if if somebody you know
when you're making allusion to people
spending X amount of dollars on the
house and and in whatever place it is I
just I think our point is that if I just
don't think you should scrutinize that
this is what I think I just and we've
talked about this I just find it weird
that for the restaurant analogy that
we've talked about if you add something
to the menu and then people show up at
the restaurant and they say what are
they doing adding something to the menu
they're just trying to make more money
it's like well it's a ridiculous walk
back to the chef and say I don't
appreciate you adding this thing to the
menu for 4 x y&z reasons because you're
just doing it for the money it's like
well if you want the new side if you
want the new green beans pay for the
green beans or not I mean and again what
if the [ __ ] these are not mythical
beasts like who are who are saying this
these are like more the casual casual
commenter kind of thing but I just don't
want to I just don't want to do to other
Creators what we don't want people to do
to us which is assess how you spend your
money you hey listen it you you can do
you can spend your money however you
want to I I'm not judging anyone for
buying a seven million dollar house I'm
just saying that we're being judged
that's not like to say that this is all
about money if I had a Lamborghini and a
seven million dollar house you could be
like okay these guys are all about money
I don't you know but could you I mean I
don't know I mean like if we didn't want
to I could say let's not hire five more
people and get in buy a Lamborghini yes
but that's not what we do we hire five
more people that's just that's how we
operate
I don't I can't fit in a Lamborghini
anyway but so the but yeah it's like
making that accusation of a rush we're
putting something else on the menu don't
see why you would complain about what
and you go back to the chef and you're
like you can complain about what the
green beans tastes like you can yeah you
have every plane about putting green
beans on the menu well it's like going
back there and complaining about new
menu items and then the chef says but
it's in my heart to make chicken nuggets
it's in my heart to add chicken nuggets
to the menu and yes if the chicken
nuggets sell well we'll make more money
and maybe we'll be able to open another
restaurant and that's good for the
economy and that's good for you and that
gives you more options and by your
restaurant closer to you and by the way
I want to buy a Lamborghini I mean okay
fine dude I mean well these are
accusations that are never levied at
traditional celebrities let me just say
that so like when people find out that
some actor gets ten million dollars to
make a movie they don't say I'm not
gonna go make I'm not gonna go watch his
work
because he got paid ten million dollars
to make that movie I'm not into this
because this is all of it yet every
movie that you watch the intention is
for it to make money everything that
you're a fan of with very very few
exceptions the intention is to make
money if you're supporting someone on
patreon you may say well why don't you
just do that why don't people just pay
you directly for what you're doing well
the reason that the person is asking you
to pay is because the intention is to
make money with it now it may not be the
first intention the first intention is
probably to be creative or to make
chicken nuggets or to do whatever but
ultimately they can't sustain it and
they can't do it because we live in a we
live in an economy we live in a world
where money is how we treat its currency
based this isn't a barter system
so because currency is involved these
things have to be financially
sustainable and I think a lot of these
comments come from kids again I think a
lot of comments come from kids who don't
understand economics and they definitely
never run a business I guarantee you
that there's not one person who owns a
business who has made that accusation
but yeah and that's why we should move
on cuz we're getting worked up but it's
not I just think it's I think it's what
we're saying because I saw I saw the
comments so many times and I took that
one personally because yeah if you tell
me that the colors off yeah you're right
if you tell me that sound off yeah
you're right we're working on it you
tell me that this particular segment
isn't funny yeah you're probably right
because if you don't think it's funny
it's not funny to you and we're gonna
try to keep me in funny but if you say
something that's just a bold-faced lie
I know that just is especially upsetting
I agree with that and I also have been
upset I guess I'm concerned and I just
wanted to say that like it's it you
listener right now are probably just as
frustrated as we are you know here's the
thing like we did that vise interview
the the like within the hour of shooting
the vlog where we responded to comments
I'm like I made the comment that during
that thing I was like I didn't know if I
was gonna start crying
I just I just had that like or if I was
just angry or you know it's just like
when you get so frustrated you just like
want it you just find yourself crying
out of like an angry frustrated cry and
that's what I described in the Vice
interview and then I I'm getting a lot
of feedback on on Twitter that people
feel sorry for me and it's you know I I
we're verbally processing this thing but
I I don't know I it's not I don't want
you guys to feel sorry for us I also
don't want you to feel like we're
accusing you I just what you know I just
want to be understood by the people who
maybe aren't even listening so that's
the that's the tough thing that's good
maybe we never will be
oh yeah we're not gonna necessarily this
wasn't about trying to change people's
minds I mean maybe some people's minds
will get changed but we just want to I
mean for what it's worth
we're verbally processing our
experiences as creators and I would like
to move back to yeah that's what I was
saying about like what what is our task
and how are we interact with that
because it's still a very emotional
thing well because I think that this
could be if any I think the person who's
gonna benefit the most from this is a
any creative person who's listening this
isn't for the for the people who are
just criticizing things just to
criticize things this is for the people
who you're gonna go and you're gonna do
something creative and you're gonna be
subjected to the same type of scrutiny
that we have been subjected to by just
being online creators and I mean
hopefully something that we've said and
something that we've offered offered
will will help give you some perspective
and kind of help you keep going because
you know it can be a difficult thing
especially if you're by yourself and I'm
not trying to shut this thing down I got
more stuff to say so this is not the end
this morning by way of another analogy
which I don't know my entire points you
can help me you're good with analogy
each morning the older kids go to school
and then I'm left with Lando to help him
get ready by the time Christie comes
back to then take Lando to school about
this
time that I leave with you for work so
my job is to make sure that Lando is
wearing clothes that match and that his
hair is put together hmm
this small task this morning I did that
and you know he invites my my input he's
like dad I'm gonna pick out the shirt
and then you pick out the pants to go
with it he doesn't like me to fix his
hair but he's gotten used to it I go
upstairs I get ready I come back down
and like Chris he's taking about the
front door and I'm telling them by for
the day and Lincoln turns it not Lincoln
Lando turns around seven years old and
he looks at me and he's got this funny
look on his face he's like what you're
wearing doesn't match and it was these
brown pants which I hardly ever wear
because I and literally I'd spent 10
minutes upstairs
right before coming out trying to figure
out what shirt what the heck shirt goes
with these pants they look like they
look like pajama pants but they could
also look like trousers that the Wright
brothers would wear I'm like I can do
this man and I'm not wearing this shirt
I'm wearing another shirt a green button
down and then Chris he's like yeah I
would just wear like I'm a monochrome
shirt like a man like a black t-shirt
with headphones on a black t-shirt and
maybe like your jean jacket but when the
seven year old that my job is to make
sure what he wears matches to all of a
sudden to hear back from him that what
I'm wearing doesn't match and he's right
just have to take and you know I think
our audience may have bristled a little
bit at one of the things that I think
maybe I said in the in the vlog and and
more when I said we don't want to just
give you what you want we want to give
you what you don't know you want yet and
I just I don't I think it may be that
that may not have settled on some ears
in the right way and I you know I don't
know they I guess for me the point of
the story is it's difficult because I do
feel like you're
this is something new but you're gonna
like it not every single thing but the
general trajectory of what we're doing
is gonna be good for you the viewer and
then when I feel like that's our job our
job is to come up with stuff that you
didn't know you wanted and give it to
you not just keep giving the same thing
anybody can do that
if you know a lot of people do that well
but then but then to hear back from them
that no this is not what I wanted and
this is how it should be is it it's for
yeah I I don't know what the word is it
it does it hurt is it frustrate hurts I
mean it definitely hurts but I mean in
some ways why creative people do
creative things is for validation I mean
that's just a that's a that's a fact of
human nature as well you know the reason
that we started being funny in front of
people is because when we were young and
we were funny in front of people it made
people like us and there's there's
there's there's sort of this empty part
of every comedian every performer that
is looking to fill that hole inside of
themselves with the response that they
can get from an audience it's an
imbalance it's like it's like an
imbalance in a battery there's a
positive and a negative charge on each
side and if that battery is completely
balanced there's no charge so I think
the imbalance within a performer is cut
they're constantly trying to balance it
out and it actually is the engine that
runs their whole system and we're no
different I mean we love it when we
create something that we love but then
the that's just like that's the opening
salvo right that's the serve and then
the volley back is the audience liking
it just like we liked it and then taking
it and understanding it and appreciating
it for all the reasons that we intended
them to that is the challenge of any
creator whether you're a painter film
maker or whatever and that's what that's
what I was saying that yeah they just
catch the ball when they just catch the
ball and say why the hell did you serve
it like that I'm not gonna volley that
back to you
what why would you do that you're like
that that hurts and you're like but you
don't understand this is like a new kind
of serve and trust me everyone's gonna
be doing this serve in ten years and we
really believe in this and we're trying
now and it doesn't always mean it's
going to work but we're not going to
stop just because the first person
doesn't hit it back we're gonna we're
gonna keep trying and keep trying and
keep finessing it and updating it well
then as our chat that's the challenge
that we've set up for ourselves because
we signed up for if you keep showering
the middle way if you keep serving it
the same way they're gonna get bored oh
yeah that's the thing is that you don't
think you're gonna get bored but people
have a tendency to kind of come into the
world of being a mythical beast and then
kind of leave you know we meet people
all the time I would say absolutely the
most common thing that we that we
conversation that we have with people
when we meet them in public is I used to
watch your videos all the time it isn't
like oh I'm a huge fan of this it's just
like yeah I used to watch your videos or
I have a we actually heard a guy the
other day say my ex-girlfriend used to
watch your videos he was like removing
himself from it as far as he possibly
could he didn't realize doesn't mean
that my response was I'm sorry
yeah it doesn't mean that you didn't
stop watching because we changed some
people may but most people are just like
I you know I just it's tough it's tough
to stay committed to something for a
long time actually the fact that we kind
of evolve and change is one of the
reasons that there's people have been
around for for a long time but but our
challenge right now is what I was saying
that we have to make this longer version
of the ship show better than just the
one segment show that it used to be yeah
the Borgata be better and then the fries
and the green beans have to have to be
better and then there's green beans at
this fast-food restaurant but that's the
one thing that's throwing me a little
bit yeah and it's like you're not fried
well we've made some green beans already
you know at the fast-food restaurant and
it's like okay are we gonna keep doing
how long are we mean how long are we
gonna keep making green beans weird
they're really lost they really lost
themselves now that they got green beans
it's tough because they're stuff that's
gonna come out that you know we don't
have your response here and we know it's
gonna be negative but we had it we we
decided to try it and it's and we don't
expect you to act like you like it
but I I do feel this pressure that like
okay do we pull back and do we just like
there was the episode with the cryo zone
like I'm so proud of that episode I was
like I told you I was like I watched the
whole thing before it went out I'm like
this is a crowd-pleaser
there's not one of these four segments
or good mythical more
that is not like anything we've done and
I felt good I felt good and then it you
know it came out and I was like the
views are down I'm hearing something's
wrong with view count but then also
people are loving the fact that we did
something like back-up plan where we
went and we we froze ourselves in these
this cryo tank and I'm like super proud
of that that we're able to bring that
back yeah and do like hopefully do more
field pieces and then we did like a
whopper Big Mac thing which is a totally
new segment and it is shorter than
anything we would have done I know I'm
getting in the weeds here but my point
is I'm very proud of that as a new type
of video that we would not have made
before but it's still fun and then then
we played a game which would normally
have been a whole episode and it was
just as good as any other game we've
played at the desk and then there was
another thing that I can't remember
right now that wasn't different than
anything we've done before and then I'm
like well you don't we don't want to
retreat back to that too soon because
then it's just more of the same it's
more before are the same thing all in
one day yeah it's like we have the
ability now to do these things that
you're not gonna like but but what we're
gonna get to is discovering the thing
that we never would have gotten to you
know I think we approach we approach
creative endeavors a lot of times as
like trying to unearth something it's in
there we just got to find it and get it
out yeah we that we actually are doing
this something nothing is planned to
fail but we know that failure will be
part of the plan so we are everything
that we put out there like we've already
already said this but we know that we're
gonna do we were going to discover that
something doesn't work and is
something new will work because that's
been sort of the method to our madness
for all these years is trying things
failing lot we failed so many times the
cool thing about this venture is that
you've got four five videos a day if you
count more where you've got so much
opportunity to kind of discover new
things and you know and I the risk is
that people will I guess the fear is
that I you know I looked up to five
videos this morning and I clicked on the
one that I liked the least and then I
read those comments and because I was
subconsciously fearful of people saying
I'm out because I think it's a
ridiculous thing to say at such an early
juncture in the evolution of the show
but at some point if we keep getting
those then that becomes the problem and
so I'm prematurely scared that people
are really gonna check out and give up
on a show because we may do the thing
just as great easily always has but
we're doing something that's like
embarrassing well I think that this is
what we signed up for you know we don't
make these videos in a vacuum we make
them for an audience the where the
intention is for the audience to love
everything and but that is never going
to be the case for them to love
everything but we want them to love the
general direction and general effort and
we want more people to be watching a
year from now than we're watching a year
ago and that's that's that's what we're
trying to do now to answer just a couple
of very specific things people are like
why don't you why can't you just make a
if you're gonna do four times the videos
why don't you just make an episode of
make for traditional episodes every
single day so it's like for ten minute
videos it's like I don't even feel like
I should have to I've seen that so many
comments many times that's not what
we're doing we're actually doing the
shorter segments because there's a lot
of shorter formatted stuff that gives us
an opportunity to experiment with
segments and little field pieces and
stuff that don't work as longer videos
but actually work better as shorter
videos so that that's why we're doing
that and then people are like how long
is this gonna go on just a month or so
it's gonna go on for at least months
it's not going to end anytime soon and
we're gonna continue to tweak it and
make it better but we have every
intention for this to be the new normal
for good mythical morning we're not
saying that it's not ever again if it
doesn't work it doesn't work and we go
back to what we used to do or something
new we don't know what we're gonna do
but we don't begin things knowing the
end we just begin things and then we
learn and we adjust so that's kind of
where we're at right now at the risk of
doing something cheesy I was I want to
read some lyrics is it from a Merle
Haggard song actually it's imminent okay
so this is gonna be a little weird I was
listening to the new Eminem song last
night have you listened to it with
Beyonce um I mean the dudes kind of
baring his soul here I just I'm just
gonna read it cuz I think it I just
really related to it where we are and
it's interesting where the song ends so
I'll get to that but why are
expectations so high is it the bar I set
my arms I stretch but I can't reach a
far cry from it or it's in my grasp but
as soon as I grab squeeze I lose my grip
like the flying trapeze into the dark I
plummet now the sky's blackening I know
the marks hi butterflies were part of my
stomach so you got this dude who is the
the like the highest-grossing artist in
history
I think he's got there's like some crazy
stat that he's like the best selling
artist ever in in I don't know Jacob can
you look that up whatever it is cuz I
don't know how he's beaten Michael
Jackson but there's some sort of there's
some mind-blowing stat that I'm sure I'm
getting wrong but you talk about this
guy you know talking about the
expectations is it based on for his for
his next rhyme and the butterflies in
his stomach you know
I don't know all the lyrics witness a
little it's a little risky to just read
Eminem lyrics blindly I've only heard
this song once but it's the curse of the
standard that the first Mathers disc set
always in search of the verse that I
haven't spit yet will this step just be
another misstep to tarnish whatever the
legacy love or respect I've garnered the
rhyme has to be perfect the delivery
flawless and it always feels like I'm
hitting the mark till I go sit in the
car listen and pick it apart hmm like
this is garbage
God's given me all this still I feel no
different regardless you know it's I
definitely feel that way it's like we
make this stuff when we try so hard and
then it's like it's just not as good as
it used to be well and here's something
that I think a lot of people I hear
people say this about people like Eminem
who've got this been around for a long
time and have been really successful
just like this guy's got more money than
God he doesn't need to work another day
in his life why doesn't this guy just
sit out in his backyard and paint right
it's like the only person who would
actually say that is a non creative
person I don't I truly don't believe
that anyone's non-creative we said in
our book that everyone's creative it's
just people don't know it yet it's like
people who say I don't remember my
dreams are people who say I don't dream
you do dream you just don't remember
them is some part of your brain you have
to unlock but I think that this
accusation our this expectation that
when somebody has seen some kind of
success that why do you sit around and
this is not we're not anything like
Eminem that's that's again we're not the
Wright brothers and we're not Eminem but
the reason that he's sitting there
toiling over this bar that he set is
because he never did it to be successful
he never did it for the money he did it
because he can't help it he's in search
of the next lyric he's in search of the
next bar that he's gonna spit and that's
what that's what keeps any creator going
is like you just what is the next thing
that we're gonna do what is the next
thing that's gonna connect and is it you
know we ever gonna connect like we used
to connect that's the fear that every
every single artist has
and I think that when you're doing it in
a place that is it's just the feedback
is so immediate and so raw and I mean
it's not the same for a guy like him
because he's not you know but because
he's so huge and so big the amount of
feedback is just an avalanche of
feedback so he discs he can read a
magazine to see what we we're not in
magazines so we can't see what people
think about us
disease we just look at YouTube comp
Annie has to craft an album I mean even
in a world of single streaming he has to
craft an album where it's like I went
away I worked on this thing I came back
and I'm slapping it down on your counter
and he can't change it once it's out
there no that's the luxury we have we
can change it what was the stat that's
selling hip hop artists in the world
best selling artist of the 2000s yep
that's what it was I knew it I knew I
had to be related to some yeah mm I mean
he goes on he his third verse he gets
even more specific about things that
he's done and then he like turns his his
mind alike what when this is over
because it will be it's like as
yesterday fades and The Dresden Home is
burnt to the ground and all that's left
of my house is lon the crowds are gone
and it's time to wash out the blonde
sales declined the curtains drawn
they're closing the set I'm still poking
my head out from behind from out behind
and everyone who has doubt remind now
take your best rhyme out do it now do it
a thousand times now let him tell you
the world no longer cares or gives a F
about your rhymes he's basically saying
all right you're gonna try it after me
and the same thing is gonna happen to
you and as I grow out of sight out of
mind I might go out of mine
he might go crazy cuz how do I ever let
this might go without a fight when I
made an effing tightrope out of twine
but when I do fall from these Heights
though I'll be fine
I won't pout or cry or spiral down or
whine but I'll decide if it's my final
bow this time around cuz and then
Beyonce sings Beyonce cuz I'm only human
just like you I've made my mistakes oh
if you only knew I don't think you
should believe in me the way you do coz
I'm terrified to let you down oh if I
walked on water
I would drown and then he's and then the
very end he's like cuz I'm just a man
but as long as I got a mic I'm godlike
so me and you are not alike I wrote Stan
and then at the end he's like I'm still
fighting so it's like goes right back in
he knows there's gonna be an end but
like I feel like that's that's that's
where we are very much engaged in a in a
creative fight I don't think it's a
fight with commenters I don't think it's
a fight with critics I don't think it's
a fight with anybody's feedback I think
it's a fight with the creative goal that
we set for ourself with ourselves it's
just it's a fight with a mountain that
we have created to say okay we are now
going to climb this hill and so I really
think that's it I don't think it's that
we're turn you know we get frustrated
with with people but and what would
comments and feedback but it's
ultimately a lot of it taps into a fear
that we're not gonna be able to
accomplish what we've set out to
accomplish and that may be embarrassing
or it may be worse it may put our
livelihood or our kids or grandkids that
we don't even have yet at least as far
as I know in in jeopardy in some way and
it's not irrational fear is an
irrational fear well it's a rush but
it's a fight that we're but the fight
that we're engaged in is creating
something that's going to express who we
are make money in the process in you
know in a way that we're not gonna
apologize for
to accomplish more of our creative
vision and we don't know if we can
accomplish it there's no guarantee that
it's gonna work when people say you guys
just killed GMM maybe we maybe we have I
don't believe that we have we wouldn't
do this if we thought that that's what
we were doing that's not why we made
this decision but the fact is is that
there's no guarantee that this is gonna
work we could have already peaked
everything's gonna be okay
it will be okay but we're not going to
stop behaving the way that we've behaved
all this this time we're not gonna stop
pushing and trying something new we're
not gonna stop creating and we're not
going to stop trying to make that next
piece of content that's gonna be better
than the last one that process is never
gonna continue now we will get we are
old we're gonna continue to get old and
older and more out of touch and more
irrelevant and then we'll be like David
Crosby's latest down which I made Linc
listen to David Crosby's album called
sky trails I think we're in an integer
so do yourself a favor and go listen to
that just as an example of where things
can end up we love you guys we
appreciate your support and yeah I think
um but that's not specifically what
we're asking for I think we're just we
appreciate you being along for the ride
we don't want your sympathy and we don't
want your sympathy likes and we don't
want your defense that's it this is just
hey we're we want to be authentic that's
one of the things that we do on air
biscuits and everything that we do but
especially here there's no there's no
script there's no plan this is just very
raw what we've been thinking about and
feeling and we wanted to share it with
you guys but don't worry about us it's
okay we're gonna be just fine we'll talk
at you next week
[Music]